what percent probability would you
currently place
on the hypothesis that covid-19 leaked
from the Wuhan Institute of virology
so I maintain a flow chart of all the
possible explanations and it doesn't
break down exactly that way
the likelihood that it emerged from a
lab is very very high
if it emerged from a lab the likelihood
that the lab was the Wuhan Institute is
very very high
the there are multiple different kinds
of evidence that point to the lab and
there are is literally no evidence that
points to Nature either the evidence
points nowhere or it points to the lab
and the lab could mean any lab but
geographically obviously the labs in
Wuhan are the most likely and the lab
that was most directly involved with
research on viruses that look like covet
that look like SARS cov2 is obviously
the place that one would start
but I would say the likelihood that this
virus came from a lab is well above 95
percent we can talk about the question
of could a virus have been brought into
the lab and escaped from there without
being modified that's also possible but
it doesn't explain any of the anomalies
in the Genome of SARS cov2
could it have been delivered from
another lab could Wuhan be a distraction
in order that we would connect the dots
in the wrong way that's conceivable I
currently have that below one percent on
my flow chart but I have a very dark
thought that somebody would would do
that almost as a a political attack on
China well it depends I don't even think
that's one possibility
sometimes when Eric and I talk about
these issues we will
generate a scenario just to prove that
something could could live in that space
right it's a placeholder for whatever
may actually have happened and so it
doesn't have to have been an attack on
China that's certainly one possibility
but I would point out
if you can predict the future
in some unusual way better than others
you can print money right that's what
markets that allow you to bet for or
against uh virtually any sector allow
you to do so you can imagine
a
simply amoral person or entity
generating a pandemic attempting to
cover their tracks because it would
allow them to bet against things like
you know cruise ships air travel
whatever it is and bet in favor of I
don't know uh
sanitizing gel and whatever else you
would do
so am I saying that I think somebody did
that no I really don't think it happened
we've seen zero evidence that this was
intentionally released
however
were it to have been intentionally
released by somebody who did not know
did not want it known where it had come
from releasing it into Wuhan would be
one way to cover their tracks so we have
to leave the possibility formally open
but acknowledge there's no evidence so
and the probability therefore is low I
tend to believe
maybe this is the optimistic nature that
I have that
people who are competent enough to do
the kind of thing we just described
are not going to do that because it
requires a certain kind of I don't want
to use the word evil but whatever word
you want to use to describe the kind of
uh disregard for human life required to
do that you're just that that that's
just not going to be coupled with
competence I feel like there's a
trade-off chart where confidence on one
axis and evils on the other and the more
evil you become the the
the
crappier you are doing great engineering
scientific work required to deliver
weapons of different kinds whether it's
bio weapons or nuclear weapons all those
kinds of things that seems to be the
lessons I I take from history but that
doesn't necessarily mean that's what's
going to be happening in the future
but to stick on the lab leak idea
because the flowchart is probably huge
here because there's a lot of
fascinating possibilities one question I
want to ask is um what would evidence
for natural Origins look like so
one piece of evidence for natural
Origins is um that it has happened in
the past
that
that viruses have jumped oh they do jump
they so like that's one like that's
possible to have happened you know so
that that's a sort of like a historical
evidence like okay well it's possible
that it hap it's not it's not evidence
of the kind you think it is it's a
justification for a presumption right
right so the presumption upon
discovering a new virus circulating is
certainly that it came from nature right
the problem is the presumption
evaporates in the face of evidence or at
least it logically should and it didn't
in this case it was maintained by people
who privately in their emails
acknowledge that they had grave doubts
about the natural origin of of this
virus
is there some other piece of evidence
that we could look for and see that
would say this increases the probability
that it's natural Origins yeah in fact
there is evidence you know I always
worry that somebody is going to
make up some evidence in order to
reverse the flow well let's say I am a
lot of incentive for that actually
there's a huge amount of incentive on
the other hand why
didn't the powers that be the powers
that lied to us about weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq why didn't they ever
fake weapons of mass destruction
interact whatever force it is I hope
that force is here too and so whatever
evidence we find is real it's the
confidence thing I'm talking about but
okay go ahead sorry well we can get back
to that but I would say yeah the the the
giant piece of evidence that will shift
the probabilities in the other direction
is the discovery of either a human
population in which the virus circulated
prior to showing up in Wuhan that would
explain where the virus learned all of
the tricks that it knew instantly upon
spreading from Wuhan so that would do it
or an animal population in which an
ancestor epidemic can be found in which
the virus learned this before jumping to
humans but I point out in that second
case
you would certainly expect to see a
great deal of evolution in the early
epidemic which we don't see so there
almost has to be a human population
somewhere else that had the virus
circulator and ancestor of the virus
that we first saw in Wuhan circulating
and it has to have gotten very
sophisticated in that prior epidemic
before hitting Wuhan in order to explain
the total lack of evolution and
extremely effective virus that emerged
at the end of 2019 so you don't believe
in the magic of evolution to spring up
with all the tricks already there like
everybody who doesn't have the tricks
they die quickly and then you just have
this beautiful virus that comes in with
a spike protein and the and the through
mutation and selection just do like the
ones that succeed
and succeed big are the ones that are
going to just spring into life with the
tricks well no
that's that's called a hopeful monster
and hopeful monsters don't work it's to
the job of becoming a new pandemic virus
is too difficult it involves two very
difficult steps and they both have to
work one is the ability to infect a
person and spread in their tissues uh
sufficient to make an infection and the
other is to jump between individuals at
a sufficient rate that it doesn't go
extinct for one reason or another
those are both very difficult jobs they
require as you describe selection and
the point is selection would leave a
mark we would see evidence that in
animals or humans both right and we see
this evolutionary choice of uh of the
virus Gathering the tricks up yeah you
would see the virus you would see the
clumsy virus get better and better and
yes I am a full believer in the power of
that process in fact I believe it uh
what I know from studying the process is
that it is much more powerful than most
people imagine that what we teach in the
evolution 101 textbook is too clumsy a
process to do what we see it doing and
that actually people should increase
their expectation of the rapidity with
which that process can produce
um just jaw-dropping adaptations
that said we just don't see evidence
that it happened here which doesn't mean
it doesn't exist but it means
in spite of immense pressure to find it
somewhere there's been no hint which
probably means it took place inside of a
laboratory so inside the laboratory gain
a function research on viruses
and I believe most of that kind of
research is doing this exact thing that
you're referring to which is accelerated
Evolution and just watching Evolution do
its thing on a bunch of viruses and
seeing what kind of tricks get developed
the other method
is uh engineering viruses so
manually adding on the tricks
what which do you think we should be
thinking about here
so mind you I learned what I know in the
aftermath of this pandemic emerging I I
started studying the question and I
would say based on the content of the
genome and other evidence in
Publications from the various Labs that
were involved in in generating this
technology
a couple of things seem likely
this SARS cov2 does not appear to be
entirely the result of either a splicing
process or serial passaging it it
appears to have both uh things in its
past
where it's at least highly likely that
it does so for example the fern cleavage
site looks very much like it was added
in to the virus and it was known that
that would increase its infectivity in
humans and increase its tropism
the uh
virus appears to be excellent at
spreading in humans and minks and
ferrets now minks and ferrets are very
closely related to each other and
ferrets are very likely to have been
used in a Serial passage experiment the
reason being that they have an ace2
receptor that looks very much like the
human acet receptor and so
were you going to passage the virus or
it's ancestor through an animal in order
to increase its infectivity in humans
which would have been necessary
uh ferrets would have been very likely
it is also quite likely that humanized
mice were utilized and it is possible
that human Airway tissue was utilized I
think it is vital that we find out what
the protocols were if this came from the
Wuhan Institute we need to know it and
we need to know what the protocols were
exactly because they will actually give
us some tools that would be useful in
fighting SARS cov2 and hopefully driving
into Extinction which ought to be our
priority
it is a priority that does not it is not
Apparent from our Behavior but it really
is uh it should be our objective if we
understood where our interests lie we
would be much more focused on it
but those protocols would tell us a
great deal if it wasn't the Wuhan
Institute we need to know that if it was
nature we need to know that and if it
was some other laboratory we need to
figure out who what and where so that we
can determine what is what we can
determine about about what was done
you're opening up my mind about why we
should
investigate why we should know the truth
of the origins of this virus so for me
personally let me just tell the story of
my own kind of Journey
when I first started looking into the
lab leak hypothesis
what became terrifying to me and
important to understand
an obvious
is the sort of like Sam Harris way of
thinking which is
it's obvious that a lab leak of a deadly
virus will eventually happen
my mind was
it doesn't even matter if it happened in
this case it's obvious there's going to
happen in the future so why the hell are
we not freaking out about this and
covid-19 is not even that deadly
relative to the possible future viruses
it's this the way I disagree with Sam on
this but he thinks about this way about
AGI as well I bought a artificial
intelligence it's a different discussion
I think but with viruses it seems like
something that could happen on the scale
of years maybe a few decades AGI is a
little bit farther out for me but it
seemed the terrifying thing it seemed
obvious that this will happen very soon
for a much deadlier virus as we get
better and better at both engineering
viruses and doing this kind of
evolutionary driven research gain
function research
okay but then you started speaking out
about this as well but also started to
say no no we should hurry up and figure
out the origins now because it will help
us figure out how to actually
respond uh to this particular virus how
to treat this particular virus what is
in terms of vaccines in terms of
antiviral drugs in terms of just and all
the the the the number of responses we
should have okay
I
still I'm much more freaking out about
the future
maybe you can
break that apart a little bit which are
you
most um
focused on now
which are you most freaking out about
now in terms of the importance of
figuring out the origins of this virus
I am most freaking out about both of
them because they're both really
important and you know we can put bounds
on this let me say first that this is a
perfect test case for the theory of
close calls because as much as covet is
a disaster it is also a close call from
which we can learn much you are
absolutely right if we keep playing this
game in the lab if we are not if we are
especially if we do it under pressure
and when we are told that a virus is
going to LEAP from nature any day and
that the more we know the better we'll
be able to fight it we're going to
create the disaster all the sooner
so yes that should be an absolute Focus
the fact that there were people saying
that this was dangerous back in 2015 uh
ought to tell us something the fact that
the system bypassed a ban and offshored
the work to China ought to tell us this
is not a Chinese failure this is a
failure of something larger and harder
to see
um
but
I also think that there's a there's a
clock ticking with respect to SARS cov2
and covid the disease that it creates
and that has to do with whether or not
we are stuck with it permanently
so if you think about the cost to
humanity of being stuck with influenza
it's an immense cost year after year and
we just stopped thinking about it
because it's there some years you get to
flu most years you don't maybe you get
the vaccine to prevent it maybe the
vaccine isn't particularly well targeted
but imagine just simply doubling that
cost
imagine we get stuck with SARS cov2 and
its descendants going forward and then
it just settles in and becomes a fact of
modern human life that would be a
disaster right the number of people we
will ultimately lose is incalculable the
amount of suffering will be caused is
incalculable the loss of well-being and
wealth incalculable so that ought to be
a very high priority driving this
extinct before it becomes permanent and
the ability to drive it extinct
goes down the longer we delay effective
responses to the extent that we let it
have this very large canvas large
numbers of people who have the disease
in which mutation and selection can
result in adaptation that we will not be
able to counter the greater its ability
to figure out features of our immune
system and use them uh to its Advantage
so I'm feeling the pressure of driving
an extinct I believe we could have
driven it extinct six months ago and we
didn't do it because of very mundane
concerns among a small number of people
and I'm not alleging that they were
Brazen about
um or that they were callous about
deaths that would be caused I have the
sense that they were working from a kind
of autopilot in which you you know let's
say you're in some kind of a corporation
a pharmaceutical Corporation you have a
a portfolio of therapies that in the
context of a pandemic might be very
lucrative those therapies have
competitors you of course want to
position your product so that it
succeeds and the competitors don't and
lo and behold at some point through
means that I think those of us on the
outside can't really uh into it you end
up saying things about competing
therapies that work better and much more
safely than the ones you're selling that
aren't true and do cause people to die
in large numbers
um but it you know it's some kind of
autopilot at least part of it is
so the there's a complicated coupling of
the autopilot of uh
institutions
companies governments
and then there's also the geopolitical
game theory thing going on where you
want to keep secrets it's the Chernobyl
thing where if you messed up
there's a big incentive I think to hide
the fact that you messed up
so how do we fix this and what's more
important to fix the autopilot which is
the response that we often criticize
about our institutions especially the
leaders in those institutions Anthony
fauci and so on as some of the members
of the scientific community
and the second part is the the game with
China
of hiding the information uh in terms of
on the fight between nations
well in our live streams on Darkhorse
Heather and I have been talking from the
beginning about the fact that although
yes what happens began in China it very
much looks like a failure of the
international scientific community
and that's frightening but it's also
hopeful in the sense that actually if we
did the right thing now we're not
navigating a puzzle about Chinese
responsibility we're navigating a
question of collective responsibility
for something that has been terribly
costly to all of us so
that's not a very
happy process but as you point out
what's at stake is in large measure at
the very least the strong possibility
this will happen again and that at some
point it will be far worse so you know
just as a person that does not learn the
lessons of their own errors doesn't get
smarter and they remain in danger we
collectively Humanity has to say well
there sure is a lot of evidence that
suggests that this is a self-inflicted
wound
when you have done something that has
caused a massive self-inflicted wound
self-inflicted wound it makes sense to
dwell on it exactly to the point that
you have learned the lesson that makes
it very very unlikely that something
similar will happen again I think this
is a good place to kind of ask you to do
almost like a thought experiment
or um
to Steel Man the argument against the
lab leak hypothesis
so
if you were to
argue uh you know you said 95 chance
that it uh the virus leave from a lab
there's a bunch of ways I think you can
argue
that even talking about it
is uh bad for the world
so I if I just put something on the
table is to say that
um
so one it would be racism versus Chinese
people
that talking about that a league from a
lab there's a kind of immediate kind of
blame and it can spiral down into this
idea that's somehow the people are
responsible for the virus and this kind
of thing
is it possible for you to come up with
other Steel Man arguments
against talking or against the
possibility of the lab leak hypothesis
well so I think steel Manning is a tool
that is extremely valuable but it's also
possible to abuse it I think that you
can only steal man a good faith argument
and the problem is we now know that we
have not been engaged in opponents who
are wielding good faith arguments
because privately their emails reflect
their own doubts and what they were
doing publicly was actually a punishment
a public punishment for those of us who
spoke up
with I think the purpose of
either backing us down or more likely
warning others not to engage in the same
kind of behavior and obviously for
people like you and me who regard
science as our likely best hope for
navigating difficult Waters
shutting down people who are using those
tools honorably is itself dishonorable
so I I don't really I don't feel that it
is
I don't feel that there's anything to
steal man and I also think
that you know immediately at the point
that the world suddenly with no new
evidence on the table switched gears
with respect to the lab leak you know at
the point that Nicholas Wade had
published his article and suddenly the
world was going to admit that this was
at least a possibility if not a
likelihood
we got to see something of the
rationalization process that had taken
place inside the institutional world and
it very definitely involved the claim
that what was being avoided was the
targeting of uh Chinese scientists
and my point would be I don't want to
see the targeting of anyone I don't want
to see racism of any kind on the other
hand once you create license to lie in
order to protect individuals when the
world has a stake in knowing what
happened then it is inevitable that that
process that license to lie will be used
by the thing that captures institutions
for its own purposes so my sense is
it may be very unfortunate if the story
of what happened here can be used
against uh Chinese people that would be
very unfortunate and as I think I
mentioned
Heather and I have taken great pains to
point out that this doesn't look like a
Chinese failure it looks like a failure
of the international scientific
community so I think it is important to
broadcast that message along with the
analysis of the evidence but no matter
what happened we have a right to know
and
um I frankly do not take the
institutional layer at its word that its
motivations are honorable and that it
was protecting you know good-hearted
scientists at the expense of the world
that explanation does not add up well
this is a very interesting question
about whether it's ever okay to lie at
the institutional layer to
protect the populace
I think both you and I are probably on
the same
have the same sense that it's a slippery
slope even if it's an effective
mechanism in the short term in the long
term it's going to be destructive
this happened with masks
this happened with with other things if
you look at just history pandemics
there's a
there's an idea that Panic is
destructive amongst the popular so you
you want to construct a narrative
whether it's a lie or not to minimize
panic
but you're suggesting that almost in all
cases and I think that was the lesson
from
the the pandemic in the early 20th
century that
lying creates distrust and distrust in
the institutions is ultimately
destructive that's your sense that lying
is not okay well okay you know there are
obviously places where complete
transparency is not a good idea right to
the extent that you broadcast a
technology that allows one individual to
hold the world hostage right obviously
you've got a something to be navigated
but in general I don't believe that the
scientific system should be
lying to us
in the case of this particular lie
the idea that the well-being of Chinese
scientists outweighs the well-being of
the world
is preposterous yeah right as you as you
point out one thing that rests on this
question is whether we continue to do
this kind of research going forward and
the scientists in question all of them
American Chinese all of them were
pushing the idea that the risk of a
zoonotic spillover event causing a major
and highly destructive pandemic was so
great that we had to risk this
now if they themselves have caused it
and if they are wrong as I believe they
are about the likelihood of a major
world pandemic spilling out of nature in
the way that they uh rode into their
Grant applications then the danger is
you know the call is coming from inside
the house and uh we have to look at that
and yes whatever we have to do to
protect scientists from retribution we
should do but we cannot
protecting them by lying to the world
and even worse
by
demonizing people like me like uh Josh
Rogan like Yuri Dagan the entire drastic
group on Twitter by demonizing us for
simply following the evidence is to set
a terrible precedent right you're
demonizing people for using the
scientific method to evaluate evidence
that is available to us in the world
what a terrible crime it is to teach
that lesson right Thou shalt not use
scientific tools no I'm sorry whatever
your license to lie is it doesn't extend
to that yeah I've seen the the attacks
on you the pressure on you has a very
important effect
on
thousands of world-class biologists
actually so at MIT colleagues of mine
people I know there's a there's a slight
pressure
to not be allowed to uh one speak
publicly and two actually think
like do you even think about these ideas
it sounds kind of ridiculous but just
the in the in the privacy of your own
home to to read things to to think it's
many people many world-class biologists
that I know will just avoid looking at
the data there's not even that many
people that are publicly opposing gain
of function research they they're
they're also like it's not worth it it's
not worth the battle and there's many
people that kind of argue that those
battles should be fought in private
in uh um you know with colleagues in the
um in the privacy of the scientific
community that the public is somehow not
maybe intelligent enough to be able to
deal with the the complexities of this
kind of discussion I don't know but the
final result is combined with the
bullying View and uh all the different
pressures in the academic institutions
is that it's just people are
self-censoring and silencing themselves
and silencing the most important thing
which is the power of their brains
like these people are brilliant and the
fact that they're not utilizing their
brain to come up with Solutions uh
outside of the conformist line of
thinking it's tragic
well it is I also think that it we have
to look at it and understand it for what
it is for one thing it's kind of a
cryptic totalitarianism somehow people's
sense of what they're allowed to think
about talk about discuss is causing them
to self-censor and I can tell you it's
causing many of them to rationalize
which is even worse they are blinding
themselves to what they can see
um but it is also the case I believe
that what you're describing about what
people said and a great many people
understood that the lab leak hypothesis
could not be taken off the table but
they didn't say so publicly and I think
that their discussions with each other
about why they did not say what they
understood that's what capture sounds
like on the inside I don't know exactly
what force captured the institutions I
don't think uh anybody knows for sure
out here in public
I don't even know that it wasn't just
simply a process but
you have these institutions they are
behaving towards a kind of somatic
obligation they have lost sight of what
they were built to accomplish and on the
inside the way they avoid going back to
their original mission is to say things
to themselves like the public can't have
this discussion it can't be trusted with
it yes we need to be able to talk about
this but it has to be private whatever
it is they say to themselves that is
what capture sounds like on the inside
it's a institutional rationalization
mechanism and it's very very deadly and
at the point you go from Lab leak to
repurposed drugs you can see that it's
very deadly in a very direct way
yeah I see this on in my field of with
uh
things like autonomous weapon systems
people in AI do not talk about the use
of AI and weapon systems they they kind
of avoid the idea that AIS use them in
the military because it's kind of funny
there is there's this like kind of
discomfort and they're like they all
hurry like uh you know like something
scary happens and a bunch of sheep kind
of like run a run away that's what it
looks like and it I don't even know what
to do about it because and then I feel
this natural pull every time I bring up
autonomous weapon systems to go along
with the Sheep there's a natural kind of
pull towards that direction because it's
like what can I do as one person
now there's currently nothing
destructive happening with autonomous
weapon systems so we're in like in the
early days of this race that in 10 20
years might become a real problem now
where the discussion we're having now
we're now facing the result of that in
the space of viruses uh like for many
years avoiding the conversations here
I don't know what to do that in the
early days
um but I think we'll have to I guess
great institutions where people can
stand out
people can stand out and like basically
be individual thinkers and break out
into all kinds of spaces of ideas that
allow us to think freely freedom of
thought and maybe that requires a
decentralization of Institutions well
years ago I came up with a concept
called cultivated insecurity
and the idea is let's just take the
example of the average Joe right the
average Joe has a job somewhere and
their mortgage their medical insurance
their retirement their connection with
the economy is to one degree or another
dependent on their relationship with the
employer
that means that there is a strong
incentive especially in any industry
where it's not easy to move from one
employer to the next there's a strong
incentive to stay in your employer's
good graces right so it creates a very
top-down Dynamic not only in terms of
who gets to tell uh other people what to
do but it really comes down to who gets
to tell other people how to think
so that's extremely dangerous
the way out of it is to cultivate
security to the extent that somebody is
in a position to go against the grain
and have it not be a catastrophe for
their family and their ability to earn
you will see that behavior a lot more so
I would argue that some of what you're
talking about is just a simple
predictable consequence of the
concentration of the uh the sources of
well-being
and that this is a solvable problem